So I'm here to talk about
model migration from Excel to R.
But I'd like to actually begin
this presentation with a story.
So this is a story about
a model migration exercise
that I did about five
or six years ago.
And it was from Excel to R,
subject of this talk. And
the ultimate outcome
of this story
was that I really improved
my programming skills
in the language R.
So, you know, this is a
positive story, right?
But I don't think it would
be interesting to tell
a story about just good
things happening to me.
I think the best
stories have conflict
and in the best stories,
things go wrong.
And this is a story,
I'm pleased to say,
where the price of my
success is that I ended up
crashing the server.
And it's doubly tragic because
not only did this happen to me,
I was also having to use Excel
day in, day out.
And I know people
in the audience,
if you've had that
experience before,
that can be a bit of a struggle.
So let me take you back
five or six years ago.
Where did this all start?
So this started with
my boss at the time.
This is my boss.
And my boss comes over
to me and he says,
Johnny, I've got a job for you.
And the job is this.
So we have a model that we've
configured in Microsoft Excel.
It's slightly complicated.
It takes multiple
people, multiple days
to actually execute
the model, and it's
highly error prone process.
So at the end of
it, we often have
to check that if
things have gone wrong,
there's a lot of validation
involved in this process.
And personally, I think would be
better suited to a programming
language like R. So would you
be interested in doing this?
So my instinctive reaction
is, yeah, that sounds great.
What's the model?
So my boss goes on to explain
it's a statistical model, OK?
And it's also a
simulation model.
So at the time I was working
in financial services.
And this was for
a banking client.
And what they were interested
in was a multiple simulations
of yearly loss scenarios.
And after those simulations
had been executed,
what they wanted
to see was, well,
if you plotted them on a
distribution, what would
the 99.9% percentile look like?
And if you think about that,
for a yearly loss distribution,
that's an event that would only
happen once in 1,000 years.
So it's pretty rare.
And the point about this is this
was not only a complicated model,
it was something that
was quite intensive.
It needed to be
run multiple times,
and I'm talking 10 to
15 million iterations.
So, you know, I was aware of
the challenge that lay before me
and so I dived into the Excel
model and it's, you know,
it's kind of hard to explain
to people who haven't worked
in financial service
or industries like this
before, where you come
across these Excel models
and they're monolithic, they're
trying to do everything.
And I think this
picture kind of sums
up the feeling of walking
into one of these things.
It's a bit like
booking an Airbnb
and you turn up in
a demolition house.
But I was resilient.
I was a resilient individual
and I understood the task
before me.
And I wanted to carry this out
and prove that I could do this.
So I opened up a
script, a single R script,
and I proceeded to copy the
contents of the Excel model
into the script.
And I basically
did this verbatim
because quite honestly,
I didn't fully
understand what was going
on in the Excel model.
And I'd also written
on my CV that I
was an advanced user of R,
which wasn't quite, quite true.
But, you know, we'll
live with that.
And I proceeded to write
the whole thing up.
This was painful,
but I got through it.
I was really proud of
myself, and I kind of
thought that by the end of this,
like, my boss is really going
to be impressed with this.
It's going to really
change the business.
So I go away to
lunch, I click Run.
And I'm like, great happy days.
I'm on cloud nine.
Then I come back from lunch and
there's a message in my inbox.
And somebody has sent an email
and it's not addressed to me.
It's addressed to the team.
That's the first kind
of sign that you've
done something really wrong.
And someone says words
to the effect of,
I can't log on to the server.
Now I'm a junior
analyst at the time,
so I don't really understand
the consequences that I
can create for other people.
So my reaction to this
is, well, that's a bit
of a shame for you, but I hope
you solve the problem soon.
And then inevitably, you
start getting other messages.
So someone else says,
yeah, I can't log on.
Someone else inevitably needs
this server for critical work
and you're blocking it.
And then eventually
someone comes to you
and they're like, do you
know what's going on, Johnny?
And my initial reaction is, no.
But then it quickly dawns
on me that I kind of
do have some idea of
what's going wrong.
That very last shred of
denial is quickly eroding.
And I finally realized
that something I've done
has caused this
mess, and I realized
that I crashed the server.
Now, I put a
celebratory emoji there
because I think this is a
bit of a badge of honor.
If you're ever involved in
this, you know, treat it
as a badge of honor.
Don't treat it as
a total failure.
You will come through
better in the end.
So this was, I jest  about this.
And it's kind of a funny
experience in hindsight,
but at the time this was
kind of a serious issue.
So I was working
an industry that is
dominated by Microsoft Excel.
In fact, Excel is
like a fortress.
Most models are
configured in Excel,
and Excel is the most
trustworthy piece
of software for many senior
executives in these scenarios.
There's a quote from The Wire.
I don't know if
anybody's seen The Wire.
The character Omar
says, if you're
going to come at the
King, you best not miss.
And I just come at the King
and I'd missed pretty badly.
I was lucky enough to have
a boss at the time who
was sympathetic enough to
persevere with this project
beyond my drastic failure.
And so what's the
moral of this story?
Uh, why am I here?
What kind of advice
can I give you?
Let's analyze what
went wrong here.
So the first big tip
I have and it's really
the biggest fundamental
problem that I encountered here
is you don't really want
to copy or replicate Excel.
OK? Now, like, this
is an obvious point
to make to people if you're
a seasoned programmer,
but let's take a step
back and put yourselves
in the shoes of somebody
who hasn't really written
much code in their life.
So somebody who's only
ever used Excel before.
For somebody like
that, everything
looks a bit like this
and that's a spreadsheet.
But if you think
about it visually,
it's a bit like a data frame
in R, and that's not a mistake.
Excel models
a lot of things
using data frames
and whilst this isn't
a problem in itself,
you end up with a
lot of Excel models
which have a few
questionable design choices.
So the first issue you
encounter typically in the wild
is Excel models, which start
out with a few number of tabs
of slowly increasing
levels of information.
And you think we're
OK, we're stable,
and then by the end of it
you've got hundreds of tabs.
And if you're the
creator of this model,
you typically end up having
a nervous sweat any time
anybody else needs to use it.
It's a very precarious
situation to be in.
And all of this comes about
because the most natural data
structure to use when
you're using Excel
is a data frame object.
So this is one issue that
you encounter sometimes.
The second is a lot
of these models,
you can store data just in a
spreadsheet or in a data frame.
So you don't really
need a database, right?
Well, not quite.
I mean, a lot of
these models probably
should be supported by a
database, but they're not.
And that's nobody's fault.
Right? Like a lot of analysts
who have built these
models don't necessarily
have the knowledge or the skills
to even think about databases,
let alone implement a database.
Certainly at the time
when I was doing this,
I wasn't aware of
this as an option.
Now, why am I
mentioning all this?
These are issues
with Excel models,
but the point is, if you're
migrating an existing
model into an R
environment, you definitely
don't want to be copying
over these design choices.
If you do this, then
you're only going
to reintroduce the problems
in a different context.
So what's my next tip
off the back of this?
So what you want to do
instead of copying what's
going on in the existing
platform, which is Excel
in this case, you want to
think about the structure
of this model.
So what you want
to do is abstract
away the implementation
that you see in Excel
and think about,
well, what is it
actually trying to do, right?
What are the functional
requirements?
What is this model
trying to achieve?
And the first fundamental
step of this process
is where does my model
begin and where does it end?
And that can be pretty
tricky with some
of these Excel models.
They are so monolithic,
that it's actually
very hard sometimes to know
where the calculations begin
and where they end.
But this is a
process that you have
to go through in order to
start unpicking this object
and migrating it across.
So this is why I have this
A to B presented here.
So you want to how do I get
from point A to point B?
That's the first ingredient.
The second thing is
well along that route.
What are the operations that I'm
applying to the data at point A
to get to point B? And if you're
doing a migration, especially
in R or any
language, really, these
are really important things
to identify because you'll
be able to encapsulate these
into functions and objects
that you can use in your
programming environment.
So this is a good kind
of planning scheme
to go through before you
actually do anything.
And the second thing
kind of related to this
is you want to think about what
are the data structures
that I need to transport
the data along this route.
OK just because the Excel
model that you're looking at
is doing everything
in Excel and you've
got multiple tabs and multiple
bits of information hanging
in memory, it
doesn't mean that you
need to do the exact same thing
when you migrate this into R.
In fact, you could
probably save a lot
of the hassle, a lot of
the overuse of this memory
and all the other problems that
come with it by just thinking
about what do I need to
retain as I go from A to B?
So let me kind of put this
into context with an example.
So I mentioned earlier that I've
been working on a simulation
model at this time.
Now, not to go into
too much detail,
but the simulation
model in each outcome,
it would generate
one simulation,
which had a set of 30
new numeric outputs
across 30 different
risk classes.
And one stage of
this model is involved
the task of trying to aggregate
these simulations together.
So the author of the Excel
model decided that, well,
the best idea that we
can use in this context
is we'll take the current
simulation that you
can see on the screen here.
And then we'll take the
previous simulations.
OK? the previous
set of simulations
will add that on to the
existing set and then
we'll get another
set of simulations
that is one row bigger
than the previous.
And that would go on recursively
until you got to, in this case,
the 15,000,000th iteration.
So, yeah, this was
something you needed
to execute across
multiple spreadsheets
and it was a slow process.
Um, but here's the
problem, right?
If you kind of
replicate this approach
and you just stick
it in an R script,
you're going to run into
trouble really quickly
and it'll look something
a bit like this.
And this is like
a classic problem
that you'll encounter in the
R programming world, which
is copying objects in
loops unnecessarily.
And unfortunately, like this
is one of the key design flaws
that I had first implemented
in my script, which
meant that this thing would
just eat up your memory
and it would keep
on going for ages.
You, you probably
wouldn't get to the end
of this on 15 million
iterations, at least
within a few days.
So this was a really
like key design
flaw in the way I'd
structured this.
So how did I fix
this in the end?
So I thought about it
in a more abstract way,
and I abstracted
away from whatever
the model was doing initially.
And I thought, well,
what I actually
need to generate here is a
list of simulation results,
and that will be equal to
the length of the number
of simulations I want to run.
And for each of these
entries in this list,
I just need a function that will
generate my simulation results
across these 30 risk classes.
And then I just need to
run this again, and again
until I get to the very end.
And then we just need
to bind these together.
So this looks simple and it was
kind of a subtly different way
of designing this, but this
very different way of doing this
was actually like a
massive improvement
on the existing script
that I'd written.
And it's small tweaks
like that where
you think about the
requirements, what you're
trying to do, which have
quite a significant effect
on the performance.
So my key tip here
as I've said already,
is to structure your model.
And the final tip I have here
is try to keep things simple.
So one of the problems
is and I don't
know what possessed me
to do this at the time,
but as a budding
analyst, I thought
it might be a good
idea to try and do
a bit of parallel
processing in this script.
And I think this
was the straw that
broke the camel's
back in my case,
coupled with some of
the other design flaws
that I'd implemented.
I was trying to do
multi-threaded processing
and it all went a bit wrong.
I didn't really read the
documentation properly
and I kind of was
overcomplicating things, right?
Like, was this really a concern
that I needed to address?
The answer is no.
Like what I really needed
to do with this process was
start simple and start
with a sample of iterations
that I'm trying to run, and
then I want to build this up,
gradually, profile what I'm
doing and work from there.
So doing the basics
right in these cases
can be really important.
So with that.
I want to thank
you for listening,
and I want to just leave
you with this quote
from Bob Ross, which I really
like, is that you make mistakes
and we all make
mistakes in life.
And it's a cliche, but
I like the addition
that mistakes are just
happy accidents, right?
Like now I can jest
about this and I
can be happy about my
accident because I actually
learned a lot in the long run.
So thank you all
for listening and.